[Música]
no último domingo mesmo março a minha
família materna organiza é aquela que é
o evento do ano é o almoço de
aniversário davam filomena ao cheiro da
cozinha frango ganha os doces
tradicionais
risos e voz desafinada
cantamos parabéns com uma alegria imensa
em março de 2018
o almoço deu lugar a um lanche a minha
avó já não ocupava o lugar do centro da
mesa estava sentada na casa das rosas ao
lado da loira e com forças que buscaram
nós não imaginávamos cumprimentava cada
um
perguntar aposentos dava nos braços
torneados e nessa mesma tarde com as
mesmas vozes afinadas cantamos parabéns
a vocês por muitos anos de vida
mas ela melhor que ninguém sabia
nos últimos meses da sua insuficiência
cardíaca tornava mais oitava e frágil
precisava de ajuda total para que o que
eram as coisas impossíveis básicas da
vila ver um copo d'água poder ir à casa
de banho cuidar da sua higiene pessoal
vivemos mais
mas será que vivemos com a mesma com o
levava ao longo dos anos que tentamos a
vida havia uma jovem impressionava
enfermeira avisa em que minha avó tem
uma doença incurável tem uma doença
terminal
imagina que eu tenho um jantar o meu vôo
resolveu falar daquilo que ela dizia que
eram as suas mãos
estados não faz xixi wu nunca para
ninguém
estou revoltada a atriz não sabe como
lidar com isto então ia medicina não tem
resposta para tudo
dizem que há tratamentos em investigação
minha voz não pode ser sobre jóias
mesmos tratamentos
a morte é considerada um tabu
as conversas sobre a mortalidade foram
desenraizados do nosso dia a dia
nós vivemos todos com prazo de validade
o envelhecimento do confronto como a
doença incurável avançada mas chegou
mais tarde teremos que levar com esta
relevado na primeira pessoa
é verdade que é um arquivo avi e os que
a taxa de mortalidade nesta sala 100 por
cento
estou a chamar a vossa atenção por certo
gostaria de falar-vos de cuidados
paliativos são canhotos salvas
oficializados estados por equipas
multiprofissionais não maria norma
medicina exigem treino formação e
prática
mas aí o zoom e cada vez mais importante
disse desmistificar conceitos errados
sobre o que são os cuidados enfim viva
ea medicina paliativa é frequente termos
cá saio e mesmo do contato com a
história do saber e não acontece só na
população em geral também os
profissionais solutione a idéia de que
os cuidados paliativos chelsea apoel
então quando já não há nada a fazer
tem que ser desmistificada
os cuidados paliativos afirmam aviva
consideram a morte como uma etapa
natural e por isso o nosso gol de
estandarte é colocar no centro da
intervenção os doentes
william é freqüente a associar os
cuidados paliativos
as doenças oncológicas os cuidados
paliativos a poeta ans as doenças
cardíacas respiratórias neurológicas e
portugal nesta aspecto ocupa o quarto
lugar do ranking nós e ver no que diz
respeito a prevalência das doenças e por
isso é imperativo que por fim o zuzu nos
próximos anos como começaremos a
preparar o futuro daquilo que são os
cuidados para cada um de nós que aqui
estamos
é fundamental instituirmos enquanto
sociedade a festa termina hoje a os
cuidados paliativos não circuito é um só
as pessoas que se aproximam do
envelhecimento são aportados em qualquer
fase do ciclo militar dia da pátria tria
aos jovens alunos e as pessoas que se
aproximam
dafne tudo com a frase levava e
vulnerável e levado o processo de
encerramento do ciclo vital o alvo ea
atenção dos cuidados paliativos não é só
o doente é tamanha família porque fui
anos com a frase levava cada agregado
familiar e nem suspeitavam nós encerrar
em si uma biografia única e pessoal
não podemos ser substituídos neste
processo e por isso o foco e atenção é
comunicação é fundamental dos montarmos
aqui o que pode ser um ato de amor mal
organizado
quando eu em peço às pessoas que é muito
mais gosto de falar sobre os seus
sentimentos e sobre as suas vivências os
cuidados paliativos são uma resposta
humanizá vá científica baseava na
medicina e nem vivência
permitem que o doente em família teve
que irão bem vazio
o nosso foco não é tanto dar mais dias a
vida passar mais vida aos dias que o
doente ea família de tânia curto o
prognóstico não é mais do que uma
incerteza ea vida das pessoas não só
médio-alto tempo mas também pela
qualidade e no que diz respeito a
terminar o iva só temos uma oportunidade
pra fazer e por isso temos que fazer
banho com o melhor das nossas
competências e capacidades enquanto só a
enquanto a enfermeira informação
avançada e os anos de experiência
permitiram me capacitar para lidar
melhor com esta realidade mas os doentes
e as famílias são os mesmos velhos
mestres senhora enfermeira e eu sinto
isso estou morrer e preciso da sua ajuda
porque a minha filha precisa de ser ver
isto
minha filha precisa se reorganizar e
para mim é importante deixar uma
mensagem e perceber que ela tem os
recursos que necessita para continuar a
sua vida é importante
mais do que saber se a pessoa sabão não
está a acontecer se eu estou capacitado
para ouvir esta mensagem e se permita
que haja um espaço de comunicação
sincero e verdadeiro e entrou doente
família profissional de saúde os
cuidados paliativos através de
intervenções rigorosas estruturadas
permitem que as pessoas saibam o motor
principal inscrevam o seu guião nesta
fase o homem que avisa e pensemos que
lidar com a morte de alguém que nos
autoriza ou não influencia só os que
estão próximos mas até é que ela como
levava local
desta forma o estado você quiser o uso
que não é possível viver esta etapa
senhora lá frontalmente e sem fazer
aquilo para menção o centro coração dos
cuidados de enfermagem permitir que as
pessoas também são este mundo tenham
acesso aos mesmos direitos e os cuidados
aqui os que nascem e esta é uma tarefa
de todos e de cada um
sabemos que em saúda os recursos são
escassos
temos hoje no panorama nacional e que
possa especializadas nesta área e em
todos os distritos pelo menos a uma
trilogia coreia do sul
integrava no sistema nacional de souza
victor forma especial aos cuidados
paliativos é seja uma evolução social
mas há um conjunto de cuidados que
depender de nós enquanto sociedade
enquanto comunidade organizarmos para
que as pessoas tenham acesso aos mesmos
ea epsilon os mesmos cuidados
a minha avó morreu a 31 de julho de 2018
no seu percurso doença
fizemos duas reuniões familiares
contratamos pessoas para que pudesse
escolher o seu local de cuidados foi a
casa do noivo sagula profissionais de
souza
reinventamos o tempo aprendemos a lidar
com as dificuldades onde havia quando
temos de cuidar daqueles que mais amamos
e de substituirmos naquilo que são as
atividades básicas da viva e tivemos que
incluir a chuva
gostava hoje do poder em que targus não
vou sair daqui é que o que dá um pode
fazer para ser a diferença ea diferença
passa por bloquear a comunicação falar
nos abertamento desta temática a rolar
no saque o que é
planejamento avançado cuidados
procurarmos a chuva como profissional de
saúde e de alguma forma conseguirmos
falar disto porque os que nos são
próximos
meu amigo o meu filho o meu pai
a segunda o segundo grande
a mensagem é a segunda mensagem à
tripulação postal as palavras de miguel
castelo-branco amigos 110 ou talvez mais
eu já contei os gostos das voz a
cortesia já fartos de ver nos cabia às
suas formaturas oi traz um dia talvez se
por fundamento
sigai docente resolvam somente que nos
fez os vossos quase o roto
estamos nos diziam a fazer-se está cego
e não nos podem ver de 199 os marotos é
difícil estar perante alguém que está
doente e do oitavo mas o todo não é
impossível
é interessante perceber que os doentes
procuram a normalização do dia pelo
menos notícias sobre o resultado do
futebol sobre o último terex sobre o
tempo que faz lá fora sobre o cheiro das
flores na primavera é isto que nos pedem
isso não soubermos nada isto dizer - uma
presença suicida e atenta de silêncio
para que os supostos dizer ou não dizer
ea terceira grande mensagem a dizer vos
que só temos uma oportunidade para fazer
e por isso temos que fazer banho e
convidados então a partilhar ea procurar
aquilo que foi o moto dentro nacional de
cuidados paliativos o astérion porque eu
importo
e é porque eu importo cada um de nós
importa fácil dito
a sociedade pensarmos a forma como vamos
cuidar das pessoas que atravessam a
última fase da vida
[Aplausos]